faites place à stéphane mal à bon soir à
tous et merci de m'accueillir ici je
suis absolument ravi d'être avec vous
pour parler de disruption avant de
commencer et vous raconter une petite
histoire ça se passe quand j'ai commencé
à travailler et quelques années j'ai eu
la chance et l'immense privilège de
travailler dans un cabinet de conseil on
m'avait dit que c'était hyper stimulant
intellectuellement on m'avait dit que
c'était prestigieux j'allais jamais
m'ennuyer etc
on voit ça s'est pas passé exactement
comme ça premier jour j'arrive dans
l'open space
je m'assois en face de l'associé qui
m'avait recruté et il m'envoie un mail
alors que on était juste en face pour me
dire et l'air occupé
quoi qu'il arrive et toujours l'air
occupé je me dis ok ce premier jour très
bien je me branche pas quelques instants
après je me lève et là je me balade dans
l'open space et je vois tout le monde
sur les écrans soit sur des sites
sportifs sont en train de faire du
shopping
je me dis est quelque chose qui va pas
dans le monde du travail
même si je débute me dit c'est un petit
peu bizarre d'un côté on met une
pression énorme pour me recruter
avec des tests hyper compétitif fait
comprendre que ça va être très complexe
énormément de challenge et cetera
de l'autre je vois aussi énormément de
gens en costume avec des cravates qui
ont l'air sérieux avec des titres très
important qui se force à parler d'une
manière que personne n'emploie dans la
vraie vie et vit de l'autre côté va on
me dit est l'ère professionnelle
je me dis bon ok c'est bizarre quelques
années après je travaille dans un grand
groupe et alors là je me rends compte
que ça empire avec les années les gens
arrivent le matin au travail
dépité le lundi ils attendent juste le
vendredi pour oublier
il parle que de leurs avantages de leurs
salaires de leurs bonus et il se
refilent des contacts entre grands
groupes pour pistonner leurs enfants je
me dis ok là il ya un sérieux problème
et en plus ça se transmet de génération
en génération
en fait ce que je découvre lorsque je
commence à travailler c'est que les gens
sont malheureux mais qui préfère être
malheureux plutôt que de changer plutôt
que d'oser le changement le problème
c'est qu'on entre dans une période
cette fameuse période de disruption où
cette attitude ne sera plus valable
où tout le monde va devoir changer
échangé à une vitesse extrêmement rapide
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il y aura de
la place et de l'eau portée des
opportunités absolument partout mais il
va falloir absolument changer cette
période de disruption dans laquelle on
entre c'est le mot qu'on entend
absolument partout que les anglo saxons
emploi tout le temps c'est une période
dans laquelle on ne vit plus une
révolution c'est à dire lorsqu'un
système arrive à bout de souffle et qui
tombe parce que des forces extérieures
le pouce mais dans laquelle on force à
rendre obsolète
absolument tout ce qui nous entoure en
utilisant la technologie
quand je dis tout ce qui nous entoure
c'est aussi bien nos métiers la manière
de travailler nos compétences nos
profils nos usages tout ça est remis en
cause en ce moment par des entrepreneurs
des start up des capitaux risqueurs aux
états unis qui se demandent pour tout ça
comment est-ce qu'on peut rendre
chacune de ces choses obsolète grâce à
la technologie la raison pour laquelle
on entre dans cette période en ce moment
c'est parce qu'on a une convergence de
technologies de plus en plus matures en
particulier intelligence artificielle
il ya une explosion ces dernières années
à propos de l'intelligence artificielle
parce que ça n'est plus de la science
fiction
depuis les années 50 on a créé on a
tenté de créer des machines
intelligentes mais on n'y arrivait pas
tout simplement parce qu'on ne savait
pas exactement ce que c'était que
l'intelligence ont programmé des
machines avec des règles sauf qu'on sait
très bien que l'intelligence c'est pas
des règles fixes du coup on a changé
d'aproz on s'est mis à entraîner à
éduquer des machines des ordinateurs
avec des données pour leur faire faire
des choses dont on dit qu'elle relève de
l'intelligence et ça marche extrêmement
bien toutes nos fonctions cognitives
sont aujourd'hui en train d'être
modéliser grâce à des algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle
pas toutes au même rythme pas tout avec
les mêmes niveaux de performance mais on
a des ordinateurs aujourd'hui capable de
mieux reconnaître leur environnement
visuel que des êtres humains
on a des intelligences artificielles
aujourd'hui capable de diagnostiquer des
cancers sur des imageries médicales
là où les médecins sont incapables de
poser des diagnostics en revanche les
machines ont toujours beaucoup de mal à
manipuler le langage soit à comprendre
le langage soit s'exprimer par elle même
mais ça va très très vite
quand je dis que toutes nos fonctions
cognitives sont en train d'être
modélisés je pense même à la créativité
tous ces sujets vont extrêmement vite ça
n'est plus de la science fiction
et ça change absolument tout dans tous
les secteurs la médecine va être
absolument révolutionné par l'arrivée
des algorithmes d'intelligence
artificielle
on va accélérer la recherche on va faire
des diagnostics beaucoup plus fiable
beaucoup plus précis on va être
meilleurs aussi dans les traitements et
on va même faire de la médecine
prédictive dans le secteur de l'énergie
on commence à faire des économies
absolument stupéfiante on à google qui
était capable de baisser de 4% sa
facture d'électricité sur le
refroidissement de ses serveurs avec une
intelligence artificielle qui vers
l'énergie
tout seul on a des algorithmes qui font
la relecture de contrats d une banque
américaine qui était capable de faire
trois cent soixante mille heures de
travail d'avocat en un peu plus d'une
seconde
tout ça c'est pas les faux chiffres
évidemment c'est les choses les plus
impressionnantes qu'on fait avec
l'intelligence artificielle en ce moment
c'est tout ce qui sort dans la presse
mais il va falloir s'y habituer parce
que tous les jours on a des progrès dans
tous les domaines et ça va beaucoup plus
vite que prévu ce que ça change dans le
monde économique et dans le monde du
business en particulier c'est que ça
change absolument tout vous savez que
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui la
connaissance n'a plus aucune valeur
économique là une valeur d'usagé qui est
considérable mais n'a plus de valeur
économique
l'entreprise ne peut plus gagner
d'argent uniquement avec de la
connaissance pourquoi tout simplement
rappelez vous vos cours d'économie c'est
la loi de l'offre parce qu'elle est
disponible en abondance la connaissance
médicale est abondante la connaissance
juridique aussi et c'est à la
connaissance et par tout ce qu'il ya de
la valeur dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
c'est le traitement de la connaissance
autrement dit les expertises
ça ne sert à rien d'avoir toute la
connaissance en abondance il beaucoup si
vous pouvez pas la traiter pouvait rien
en faire donc dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui celle expertise qui a de
la valeur
mais grâce à l'arrivée de l'intelligence
artificielle puisqu'on de programmes
plus des machines mais qu on les
entraîne à atteindre des objectifs
les expertises aussi deviendra une
commodité et n'aura plus de valeur
économique
c'est le médecin qui entraîne
l'intelligence artificielle à
reconnaître des cancers sur l'imagerie
médicale
c'est l'avocat qui entraîne
l'intelligence artificielle a
sélectionné des arguments pour une
plaidoirie à les structurer à l'étrier à
mettre des probabilités de raisonnement
d'un juge en face etc
c'est même le programmeur informatique
qui entraîne l'intelligence artificielle
a généré son propre code
on a même des intelligences
artificielles qui génère d'autres
intelligences artificielles aujourd'hui
tous les métiers sont concernés
donc la connaissance n'a plus de valeur
économique
demain les expertises n'aura plus est
entre nous c'est une excellente nouvelle
pourquoi parce que nous les êtres
humains on n'est pas bons en expertise
on est très arrogant sur notre
intelligence d'ailleurs on n'arrête pas
de comparer les machines à d'autres
propre intelligence en se demandant si
elles vont nous dépasser ou pas comme
vous le disais c'est déjà fait sur le la
capacité à reconnaître ce qui assure des
images médicales
mais ce qu'on ne voit pas sur tout c'est
qu'on est très mauvais en expertise
prenez trois experts ou quatre experts
dans n'importe quel domaine ils ont tous
des expertises des avis des diagnostics
différent ça marche pour des médecins
les avocats
même les garagistes an le gard jc
peut-être encore autre chose on est on
est très mauvais en expertise grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle les êtres
humains vont perdre l'expertisé
puisqu'on va confier tout ça aux
algorithmes on va faire monter le niveau
d' expertise qu'est-ce qui nous restera
pour nous différencier et créer de la
valeur nous les êtres humains tout
simplement les trucs où on est bon nous
les êtres humains l'empathie l'humour
l'amour la confiance la relation
l'interaction avec l'autre vous dirai
plus demain chez votre médecin pour
votre pour son expertise médicale
puisque ce sera fait par des algorithmes
et c'est bien mieux pour tout le monde
mais vous continuerez à aller dans le
cabinet du médecin par
il vous écoute parce qu'il vous rassure
parce qu'il vous conseille parce qu'ils
aient un lien empathique extrêmement
fort entre vous et lui ça s'appelle
l'effet placebo l'effet placebo chez les
êtres humains et les considérables pour
les chez les médecins c'est 30 à 35% en
moyenne cette généraliste vous sentez 30
à 35 pour son mieux en sortant du
cabinet du généraliste alors qu'il n'a
rien fait cet effet placebo il est
extrêmement important pour les êtres
humains
il existe dans tous les domaines pas
dans les mêmes proportions mais dans une
négociation d'affaires dans une campagne
politique dans une campagne de
communication dans une discussion avec
les autres cet effet placebo il est
considérable nous les êtres humains on
va se différencier là dessus l'enjeu de
demain pour les individus et pour les
entreprises ça va être d'avoir ses
compétences d'excellents êtres humains
dans les interactions
on appelle ça des softs qu'ils ça veut
dire être capable de réagir avec
empathie avec l'autre pour pouvoir être
vu comme quelqu'un de confiance parce
qu'il faut se dire quelque chose c'est
qu'on entre dans un monde algorithmique
où l'intelligence artificielle sera
partout et l'enjeu ça sera aussi de
convaincre ses algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle de notre
niveau d'empathie et de confiance
les entreprises demain ne vont plus
convaincre leurs clients elles vont
devoir convaincre les intelligences
artificielles les algorithmes filtre
algorithmique de leurs clients qui
seront disponibles sur les smartphones
du futur où les dispositifs qui
existeront demain l'enjeu est
considérable dans cette phase de
disruption au regard de l'empathie
la deuxième chose qui risque d'être
assez surprenante pour les êtres humains
avec l'arrivée de l'intelligence
artificielle c'est qu'on est en train de
se rendre compte et ça ça va être une
blessure narcissique pour beaucoup
d'entre nous qu'on est beaucoup plus
prévisible qu'on le pense ça il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui vont avoir
énormément de mal à l'accepter
on sait déjà des choses comme ça en
sciences sociales
le rôle des sciences sociales de
l'économie de l'économétrie notamment de
trouver des corrélations des variables
indirectes pour découvrir déduire des
choses à propos de vous à propos des
entreprises lorsqu'elles n'ont pas
l'information simplement parc aux
rédactions par corrélation savez
lorsqu'un assureur vous fait remplir un
formulaire
ils vous demandent certaines choses mais
en réalité c'est pas ça qui va
perez il veut juste déduire des
chaussures vous n'allez pas lui dire
avec le bon modèle assurantielle
simplement avec les données xavier mise
dans le formulaire
mais là où je veux en venir c'est
qu'avec l'arrivée de l'intelligence
artificielle
on va en permanence être évalués et on
va déduire plein de choses sur nous à
notre comportement avec la technologie
tous les logiciels que vous utiliserez
toutes les technologies que vous
utiliserez seront connectés à des
algorithmes d'intelligence artificielle
qui vont vous analyser en permanence
pour déduire des choses à propos de vous
c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
lorsque vous utilisez une plateforme
comme facebook à l'heure à laquelle vous
l'utilisez à la fréquence d'utilisation
de la plateforme a qui sont vos amis à
ce que vous postez vous ne postez pas
d'ailleurs a encore une fois les choses
comme le déplacement de la souris sur
les grands trucs aussi bête que ça
facebook est capable de déduire des
choses assez stupéfiante
ils sont capables d'anticiper si vous
avez un risque de vous suicider de
manière imminente et ils ont sauvé des
vies comme ça ça marche très très bien
simplement à l'utilisation de la
plateforme ils sont capables aussi de
connaître vos humeurs en temps réel et
même d'influencer vos humeurs sont
capables de savoir pour qui vous allez
voter et même d' influencer votre vote
comme on l'a vu dans la presse avec le
scandale gamebridge analytica et ils
sont même en mesure de savoir si vous
allez vous mettre en relation avec
quelqu'un
wen de vous séparer on est beaucoup plus
prévisible qu'on le pense et en
utilisant la technologie on va sans
rendre de compte de plus en plus ça va
être une blessure narcissique énorme
pour la plupart d'entre nous le problème
de cette période de disruption dans
laquelle on entre comme je le disais
c'est qu'elle cherche à rendre obsolète
toutes nos manières de faire de penser
de voir le monde et d'agir aujourd'hui
ce qui veut dire que pour se préparer à
cette période de disruption il va
falloir adopter ces modèles l'enjeu en
ce moment pour les entreprises c'est de
faire une transformation digitale
vraiment dit s essaye de mettre du
digital et en particulier de
l'intelligence artificielle dans toutes
leurs processus dans leur manière de
faire autrement dit elles essaient de
mieux faire lormes
ethier leur coeur de métier avec la
technologie
c'est la pire erreur à faire avec
l'arrivée de l'intelligence artificielle
vous savez comment ça s'appelle partir
de son coeur de métier de ses
compétences
essayer de mieux le faire d'être plus
productifs d'être plus performant grâce
à toutes ces technologies
ça s'appelle kodak ça s'appelle
blackberry ça s'appelle yahoo
ça s'appelle tous ceux là qui ont
disparu et bien d'autres pourquoi parce
que tous ces acteurs ils sont partis de
leur coeur de métier
kodak son métier c'était d'imprimer des
photos et sont demandés comment mieux
faire leur métier avec le digital kodak
avait inventé le numérique ils n'y ont
pas cru sont trompés mais lorsque
l'appareil numérique a commencé à
décoller a commencé à prendre beaucoup
de photos avec nos smartphones ils sont
dix génial métier c'est d'imprimer des
photos on va faire fortune
les gens vont imprimer plein de photos
jamais il aurait imaginé que les gens
arrêteraient de prendre des photos pour
les imprimés physiquement mais qui les
regarderai uniquement sur les réseaux
sociaux sur leur smartphone autrement
dit dans la période de disruption dans
laquelle on entre il ne faut surtout pas
partir de ses compétences et de son
coeur de métier mais imaginez que ça a
déjà disparu que c'est déjà devenu
obsolète et vous savez quand on regarde
la différence entre les entreprises
traditionnelles et les dix rupteur
particulier dans la silicon valley qui
font ça tout le temps c'est assez
radical il sera acteur font ça tout le
temps
netflix par exemple spécialiste de la
vidéo en ligne
ils ont fait ça plusieurs fois au départ
netflix les envoyés des dvd par la poste
sauf qu'ils sont des 1 c'est fini les
dvd maintenant on va faire du streaming
va faire de la vidéo en ligne
alors quand le patron a annoncé ça aux
investisseurs déjà ils ont fait une
crise cardiaque sondés mais il est fou
c'est super rentable c'est notre coeur
de métier on gagne plein d'argent hors
de question j'ai les achever mais il
était plus loin il leur a dit non
seulement on va faire de la vidéo en
ligne la vidéo en ligne
ça vaudra 0 ça deviendra une commodité
or là sont par terre les investisseurs
il veut tuer notre business pour un truc
qui rassure valeur parce que ce que
pensait le patron de netflix
c'est que la valeur ça allait être une
expérience exceptionnelle avec une
interface design etc
des algorithmes de recommandations qui
en fonction de redonner vous recommande
quels films ou séries regarder et en
plus de ça maintenant la production de
films et de séries
c'est ça la valeur de netflix autrement
dit ils ont sabordé leur actif leur
rentabilité et leur coeur de métier pour
inventer autre chose mais maintenant le
patron de netflix il va encore plus loin
il a déclaré récemment qu'avec l'arrivée
de toutes ces nouvelles technologies des
biotechnologies les découvertes en
neurosciences le futur du divertissement
ça ne serait plus de regarder un film ce
serait d'aller dans le film et il
pensait pas au casque de réalité
virtuelle augmentée à toutes ces
technologies kong en ce moment il
pensait à des espèces de drogues
hallucinogènes comme le lsd les
champignons enfin un truc mais un truc
parfaitement légale un encadré par les
autorités validé par les professionnels
de santé quelque chose de totalement
légale qui rappelle d'ailleurs le soma
dans le meilleur des mondes pour ceux
qui ont lu aldous huxley là où il
voulait en venir c'est que la disruption
du divertissement allait venir de
l'extérieur secteur du divertissement
que ça va être les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques qui allait investir le
secteur du divertissement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que dans la période de disruption qu'on
est en train de bien en ce moment avec
l'arrivée de l'intelligence artificielle
personne n'est à l'abri c'est ça la
bonne nouvelle tout le monde est dans le
même bateau peu importe notre industrie
notre secteur notre profit nos
compétences notre formation
tout le monde est concerné mais surtout
le changement est obligatoire est pire
que ça parce que sans nous le dit tout
le temps que le changement est
obligatoire pour réussir il faut se
saborder il faut se rendre soit même
obsolète
pourquoi parce que si vous le faites pas
quelqu'un quelque part une start-up un
entrepreneur est en train de rendre
votre métier votre vos compétences votre
profil obsolète et ça c'est une
excellente nouvelle
et pourquoi parce qu'en fait si on prend
les métiers par exemple si un métier a
besoin d'être fait aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il existe un problème
et si on est capable de rendre ce
problème obsolète on leur a fait
disparaître et on pourra se consacrer à
un autre problème est souvent
effectivement quand on est concerné par
ce métier qu'on fait disparaître ça nous
pose un problème
quelles activités on va faire etc mais
en réalité dans certains cas on est
content de faire disparaître ce problème
je faisais une conférence récemment pour
des experts comptables et je leur ai dit
mais qui aime la comptabilité parmi vous
on a pas un seul qui a levé la main l'a
dit mais vous serez content si on
disposition faisait disparaître la
comptabilité en l'automatisant avec
l'intelligence artificielle on aura
résolu le problème de la comptabilité
plus besoin d'enfants on pourra passer à
d'autres problèmes ils m'ont dit oui
effectivement mais qu'est ce qu'on va
faire de nos vies ça aucune inquiétude
parce que dans le monde dans lequel on
entre on a plein d'opportunités
absolument partout c'est vrai qu'il ya
une inconnue sur le nombre d'emplois
qu'on va recréer dans cette révolution
on ne sait pas si on va recréer autant
voire plus d'emplois que ce qu'on va
détruire
il ya deux écoles là dessus ce qu'ils
nous disent
l'histoire va se répéter la technologie
a toujours détruit des emplois mais on
en a créé d'autres qu'on ne connaît pas
je vous petter la destruction créatrice
c'est plutôt des économistes qui nous
disent ça habituellement de l'autre côté
cette fois on trouve des visionnaires ou
des gens comme bill gates comme ils
osent musk comme stephen hawking comme
le patron du ber patron d'airbnb les
gens comme ça qu'ils le disent non dans
cette fois ci c'est différent cette
fois-ci c'est différent parce qu'avec
l'intelligence artificielle on s'attaque
à la dernière spécificité de l'être
humain au travail on s'attaque à son
intelligence
comment recréer des jobs si ce qui nous
permettait d'en recréer avant notre
intelligence est en train d'être
modélisés on a ces deux écoles en ce
moment impossible de connaître la
réponse savoir si on va recréer plus de
job que ce mois que ce qu'on va détruire
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il ya
tellement de nouveautés dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui que si on s'amuse soi même
à se rendre obsolète pour l'instant il
ya énormément de choses très excitantes
à réinventer dans tous les domaines on
n'est pas encore à cette période où les
machines ont pris tous les jobs si c'est
ce scénario qui serait elle
donc n'ayons pas peur de cette nouvelle
cette nouvelle vague entrons dans la
disruption gardons en tête que nous
sommes tous concernés et surtout voyons
les opportunités pour l'humanité voyons
la valeur que sacré pensons aux maladies
qu'on va guérir très vite avec ses
algorithmes qui vont accélérer la
recherche
pensons aux vies qu'on va sauver sur les
routes avec les voitures sans chauffeur
connecter tout ça c'est de la valeur
mais pour accélérer cette rentrée dans
la disruption il faut que chacun cherche
à se rendre obsolète pour se réinventer
merci à tous de votre attention
[Applaudissements]